the first question to Mike Pence in
tonight's vice presidential debate
should not be about Donald Trump's tax
avoidance it should be does Donald Trump
believe in democratic elections in this
country it was perhaps the first sane
moment of Trump's campaign it appears it
was his last within 96 hours he had
repudiated that moment and that
repudiation was the most Craven and
cowardly act not just of this election
not just of this campaign but by any
presidential candidate since the Civil
War and it was lost in the shuffle
something on America something
unbelievable something unconscionable
and it barely registered buried amid the
emotional debris of an unstable
megalomaniac raining down upon the
nation the quote genius unquote who
claimed poor people weren't paying
enough taxes when he may have paid none
for 18 years a debate over non-existent
sex tapes controversy over who will
tweet at 3:00 a.m. invocations of
marital infidelity cheating at charity
cheating at illegal trade with foreign
nations lost in the avalanche of
stupidity and self-obsession and
hypocrisy from this idiot Trump missed
in large part because there are a dozen
things a day any one of which should
disqualify him from residency let alone
presidency and yet he said it as glibly
as if he were unhappy about a local
zoning board decision one of you will
not win this election debate moderator
Lester Holt had said are you willing to
accept the outcome as the will of the
voters and Trump could not simply answer
it he first had to wade through the
involuntary egotism and spasmodic
salesmanship with which he thinks he is
cloaking the most insecure man of our
times from public view but finally he
said it if she wins I will absolutely
support her the first thing he has yet
said that indicated that for a moment
just for a moment he could put America
ahead of his own ego ahead of his own
naked lust for power and control control
not just of a company or a television
show where what he says is the rule but
of a nation in what he says is the law
and it was just for a moment for then
the impact of his failures at the debate
at him and the pattern of whatever is
wrong with him
stopped waning and started waxing and
Trump took it back late last Friday
Trump told the New York Times he was
rethinking his statement rethinking
whether or not to recognize the outcome
of the presidential elections next month
we're going to have to see we're going
to have to see what happens we're going
to have to see no presidential candidate
no political party no leading government
figure no member of the military no
prominent commentator nor leader of any
kind is permitted to raise such doubt
the sanctity of the election is the
bedrock of this country not the
Constitution not the Bill of Rights not
the military not the founding fathers
there is only one response permissible
to a question about the outcome of the
election acceptance merely to hesitate
even in the most trying of circumstances
in the midst of legal actions by both
sides in the immediate aftermath of as
close a vote as could be imagined is to
change one's reputation forever as it
did that of Al Gore to hesitate and be
judged in the legal right still
eternally alters a man's place in
history as it did that of George W Bush
Richard Nixon who craved the presidency
more and more ominously than any other
man who attained it even he did not move
to formally contest the razor thin
margin of 1960 and he certainly did not
imply he would not nor others should not
recognize it Samuel Tilden denied the
presidency in 1877 in a fateful bargain
between the Democrats and Republicans
that sanctify Jim Crow in this country
for 80 years still walked away even at a
time when the sitting president had
quietly strengthened the military
presence in Washington over rumors of
armed revolt no matter who won the
election even as members of the US
military supposedly offered Tilden
support to overturn that election by
force
Tilden still obeyed Abraham Lincoln when
he thought as late as September 1st 1864
that he would lose reelection to General
George McClellan and the Democrats
he was ready to leave office in the
middle of the civil war and honor the
election and Nixon and gore and Hubert
Humphrey in 1968 and Charles Evans
Hughes in 1960 and Andrew Jackson in
1824 and all the other losers in all the
other impossibly tight elections in our
history not only never raised a serious
doubt about the legitimacy of their own
defeat after it happened even when as in
Tilden's case the flaming torch of Civil
War had been one side's recourse just
for elections previously but none of
them ever would have dreamed in a dozen
lifetimes to threaten not to recognize
the election before the election
happened Trump you are a child throwing
matches at a gasoline can you are
pulling on the loose thread that every
winner every loser every saint every
devil and everyone else who has ever
sought the presidency has known better
than to touch you are denying the
fundament of democracy betraying the
history of your party your people your
nation Trump you are fomenting
revolution there is no margin for error
here because no Trump we are not going
to have to see what we are going to do
we Americans after that remark I don't
know what you are what we are going to
do is to honor the 57 elections that
have gone before even if they're hacked
by the Russians who you like far too
much to make thinking men and women do
anything but cringe and if we don't like
the outcome we will act to remedy it
within the Constitution opposition
protest impeachment even formal
contestation all of it legal ethical
often necessary to the life of the
nation but nobody Trump who believes in
democracy Republican or Democrat
conservative or liberal first says he
will absolutely support the free
elections that have kept us free for 240
years and then within the week because
he doesn't like the polls because he
doesn't like the commentators because he
doesn't get his way suddenly switches to
we're going to have to see Trump you are
by yourself and as a representative of a
brutal minority in this country a threat
to the very democracy that permits us
savage like you to rise this far and get
this close to the life-and-death power
of the presidency in the kind of
nightmare country you invoke just by
using the very phrase we're going to
have to see your presidential
aspirations would have ended long ago
and not by legal means but this is
America and this is democracy and even
when nearly two and a half centuries
worth of process and law and good
fortune comes to a sudden end and the
system spits up someone wholly
unqualified for office nowhere is it
written that the rest of us can simply
say we're going to have to see if we
will support the outcome of this
election even if it led to the
cataclysmic nightmare of your
administration Trump we would stay and
fight you through the law through the
Constitution through the Constitution
and for those things the founding
fathers risked their lives their
fortunes their sacred honor for those
things every soldier who ever wore this
nation's colors fought for those things
every Patriot willingly offered up all
they knew and loved and the first of
those things Trump is the sanctity of
the election if you cannot now hold to a
pledge to honor and accept its outcome
for more than 96 hours you are not a
president you are not a man of freedom
you are not an American get out out of
this race now before you damage this
democracy still further get out out of
this country now before the cowards and
fascists and bigots who have rallied
around you for a year begin to believe
that their subversion of democracy will
be permitted here you would fit in
perfectly in the new government of the
Philippines you like Russia I'm sure
they can find people for you to dictate
to and oppress there get out Trump for
once in your life recognize that
something is not about you nor is it
about your opponent nor the Democrats
nor the Republicans it is about the
essence of the United States of America
and you do not have the option to say
we're going to have to see 240 years of
Patriots blood and
respect for law will not be sacrificed
at the gold-plated altar of your sick
and demented and morally treasonous ego
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space